[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists 11 years of less
that's right ryan yeah man today is
december 14th
which is officially the 11 year
anniversary of the minimalists how cool
is that man did you think this would
last 11 years
i didn't have an expectation around it
thankfully yeah me either but on today's
podcast that's what we're going to talk
about we're going to talk about what
we've learned what we've how we've grown
and in what ways we've subtracted
then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast ryan and i are going to
talk about
well we're going to talk about our many
personal failures over the last 11 years
you can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
ryan our first question today is from
jill on facebook how is your
understanding of and approach towards
minimalism developed over the last seven
years
i think my approach has probably
changed the same way many people's
approach changes
ryan and i will often say that
minimalism starts with the stuff and so
for me it truly started with the stuff
you can call it decluttering you can
call it letting go tidying up there are
all kinds of monikers we can give it
but it was really about it was a
reaction to being overwhelmed
by
stuff yeah i had too much stuff in my
life but it turns out that our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of what's going on inside us i knew i
had a lot of external clutter what i
didn't know is i had a lot of social
clutter relationship clutter career
clutter psychological clutter emotional
clutter spiritual clutter calendar
clutter obligation clutter there's a lot
of internal mental and emotional clutter
going on inside me and as soon as i
started letting go i i started looking
inward and realizing like oh my gosh
there is so much that i still need to
deal with and and at first
when you start to understand the truth
about your stuff and your relationship
with stuff
it causes actually more turmoil
because it's like
oh
i thought things were fine and maybe i
was just one solution away from solving
all of my problems
but then i realized no no there are
actually
more
problems and i was covering them up
you know i think about my mom when when
she died because that's how we kind of
started the whole minimalist thing when
when she died i started questioning
everything she died of stage four lung
cancer
had she caught that cancer earlier stage
one
she may have been able to eradicate it
right but instead we wait we wait we
wait until it has metastasized
all over our lives
and i felt like i just had
this sort of metastase of of clutter
throughout every area of my life and why
why do we do that well i did it because
i wanted to be accepted i wanted to be
successful i wanted to be better i
wanted to be improved i wanted to be
the best version of myself or whatever
that that meant but it was all by
someone else's standards if i buy the
right thing have the right relationship
have the right job live in the right
house own the right car
then i will be the right person
but of course it never worked in fact it
took me so far away from being the
person i wanted to be
yeah it's interesting the uh
metastasizing comment makes me think
about
how you know often people will ask would
you have to have like a major life event
happen to like
be inspired to be a minimalist
and unfortunately
i think that's probably how most people
start down this road
is because they
wait and wait and wait and keep putting
things off until you get to a boiling
point it's almost like
um someone who's in a job that they
really hate like should i quit my job
right now because it's like well no you
should have quit it like
a year ago but but a year prior to that
year you should have planned an exit and
like now you're at this point where like
you feel like you have to do something
radical
um and i'll you know for me and i
definitely felt like i had to do
something radical where i was on my life
so minimalism it was like radical enough
not because
not for any other reason then
i needed
to change my state i needed a different
perspective on how i was approaching my
life so that's what i saw
minimalism as an opportunity now this
question asks over the last 11 years
but technically it's been you've been
doing this for about 12 plus years right
yeah and you've been doing it for over
11. what's what's fascinating is this
year 2021
is our 30th anniversary ryan you and i
have known each other since 1991. yeah
that's wild and we've been great friends
and on the maximal episode this week i
actually want to go back to our
childhood and talk a little bit about
how the narrative overlay is ryan and i
have been best friends since we were fat
little fifth graders and while that's
partially true it's not the whole story
and we've had times in our lives where
we've grown apart and we've come back
together and so i want to talk to you
about a lot of that yeah you use this
word radical and what's so fascinating
about it is you're right minimalism does
seem so radical to certain people but
the reason it does is because
we've been doing all of these radical
things yeah we've been steeped
in
radness radicalness yeah and we've had
so you know having 300 000 items in your
home was it that's normal it's normal
now yeah that's what we what i mean by
normal right it's it's average it's the
norm right yeah and yet
if you look 100 years ago 200 years ago
a thousand years ago
that's so radical and unheard of kings
didn't have 300 000 items in their home
dude native americans thought it was a
uh a mental illness
it is yes really i mean so
we are like the level of hoarding we
have now it's an acceptable level of
hoarding because it's average
yeah but you're right a thousand years
ago they would have looked at us like
why are you holding on to so much stuff
right you and your possessions and the
me the mind i'm not against having
personal possessions obviously i have
plenty of them but i do have a problem
with the clinging and we quite often
cling with oh that's mine
in fact we see it manifest a mental
illness there's a guy across the street
this this morning you and i saw him yeah
he uh he's been living literally across
the street from the studio here and he
is i mean he's a traditionally mentally
ill hoarder
and yeah i mean i feel so bad for him
but there's a guy who bought the
building across the street and he even
offered him money and try to help him
out get out of here can i get you
housing is there something i can do here
and the guy has simply refused but he
has i mean i feel like he has 300 000
items across the street you can't even
walk down the sidewalk where he is
anymore and you know it's that's a great
observation because people will often
ask like well how does how does a
homeless person use minimalism in their
life and i agree like there there are
different um
people are on a different socioeconomic
scale my problems are different from a
homeless person's problems right but
using that person as an example
um
he was he's in such a scarcity mindset
that he holds on to every single thing
that's right which actually ends up
being a detriment to him yeah in fact
you and i grew up really poor
you know we hear people all the time so
yeah i i uh i'm poor that means i'm a
minimalist right i was like well no we
we definitely weren't minimalists when
we were growing up by the way you're
american poor which is way different
than poor poor yeah here's here's a stat
for you do you make 32 000 or more if so
you're in the top one percent of people
in the world yeah that's crazy you
you're a one percenter right 16 bucks an
hour by the way and and so like
what's fascinating is
we
can get out of poverty
but we often don't get out of the
poverty mindset yeah and that's where
ryan and i were we still had a scarcity
mindset we left
behind where we grew up we climbed the
corporate ladder we spent here's the
weird thing ryan next year will be 12
years for us
i spent 12 and so it's 12 years for me
right now uh minimalism since i
discovered minimalism and it came into
my life
and
i didn't discover it by the way like i
mean i discovered the way same way
christopher columbus discovered america
right ben franklin discovered
electricity yes like minimalism was
already there i happened to stumble into
it you uncovered it yes i uncovered it
for me anyway it's been 12 years for me
since i simplified my life a little bit
over 12 years at this point so it was
what was that 2009 when my mom died
and my marriage ended both in the same
year in the same month
that year and i started looking around
and i realized like oh i'd spent the
last 12 years in the corporate world
climbing the corporate ladder but i
still had that scarcity mindset yeah i
was still
clinging grasping now i was clinging to
different things and and i was told that
they were better things but they weren't
better they were societally acceptable
clinging
yeah i was holding on to status
achievement success etc
and there's nothing wrong with those
things as a byproduct but if i think
they're going to make me happy fulfilled
complete
it's just another form of consumerism
and even when walking away from that
world and becoming the minimalist i've
seen times where it's like oh yeah
here's the right way to be successful
well that can also turn into another
form of consumerism yeah and so here's
the main lesson that i've learned yeah
it's gonna ask you like if you had to
highlight it all your understandings how
they've changed consumerism extends well
beyond the stuff
oh yeah for sure consumerism is the
ideology that buying things is going to
make me happy or complete
but we often shift that well i'll get
rid of my things and now i'm going to be
a consumer of experiences
experiences are great i really enjoy
them in fact the one way to be present
is to experience life however if we
start chasing experiences if i just had
this experience then i would be happy if
i just had this experience then i'd be
fulfilled if i had this experience it
would be better than owning stuff
well maybe but maybe it's also a chase
and so any chase often takes away my
freedom
and i value freedom i value peace i
value tranquility in a way that i didn't
value it in my 20s and it's not good
you'd say that you should value peace
it's just i would say that i wanted
freedom i would say that i wanted peace
but then my actions
would be everything that took me out of
peace
added chaos disorder
to my life yeah
man i could go on this entire podcast
about how my
how my opinion or my understanding of an
approach towards minimalism has changed
some of the things that stand out is uh
so for me minimalism there there is no
destination you never have the perfect
amount of stuff right it is a
it is a constant
moving target that you have to
adjust for as time goes on
and uh if anything it's just made me
more flexible to
um
towards change
the other thing too is
so we've been i was just listening to
this i forget who wrote it but it's a
book on stoicism and they're talk they
were talking about how
pre-post-industrial age
the um
the message propagated was
there's a gods there's a god-shaped hole
in your life yes and like that's what
you're missing missing god in your life
and now post industrialization there is
a consumerism
shaped hole in our life yeah and in a
lot of ways the god-shaped hole can
still you know apply to today
so i thought minimalism was gonna fill
this hole i thought it was gonna like
not make me complete but i thought it
was going to
help me
move through life in a way
where i didn't feel like i was missing
something it would fix the problem yeah
so i don't i don't miss anything i don't
feel like i'm missing anything but
there's still a little bit of a of a
void there
and what i've learned
from this journey over the last 11 12
years
is that
that void
it is so much better
to like instead of like
you know in a car driving away from that
void
it's like i i
have it in the passenger seat with me
and really understanding
that there's nothing that will ever fill
that void there might be a brief instant
where
you know i feel like oh everything's
perfect right now and it and it's true
for that moment but that void will
always come back in some way so for me
minimalism doesn't fill the void
what it does is it narrows it
and
it has really helped me accept it if
that like i'm friends with the void now
yeah in fact it's made you realize that
there isn't a should fill the void right
and and i think that's the problem in
fact we use the word void as though it's
pejorative i was having this great
conversation with danny this weekend we
were here trying to hang these these
paintings that are behind us that didn't
get
hung um and so you're in a weird sort of
transitional pace space of the studio
right now but danny and i were talking
about how a lot of these words are used
pejoratively
and you know there's a word like um
inferior yeah like
well of course
you look at that and we've been
programmed to think oh that's bad right
but like if you actually want to grow
you want to be inferior to the person
you're learning from yeah i was telling
danny like there's nothing i can teach
you about audio video stuff now i can
guide you through
your own growth here in so many other
ways but i'm inferior to danny with
respect to audio video yeah now it
doesn't mean i couldn't change that in
the future but in fact if i wanted to
learn audio video i love how the caveat
is in there i could i could totally not
be inferior though if i anyway well what
i'm saying is like if i felt compelled
to do audio video stuff yes then i'm
sure i could get good at i'm just not
i'm not compelled to do it really right
but he and jordan are compelled and so
what's fascinating is if i wanted to
become
better more nuanced have a deeper
understanding of of the audio video
stuff then i would subordinate myself to
danny because that's how i would learn
from that absolutely being inferior is
actually what you want in that instance
take that back to the void i want the
void because what's the opposite if you
go into a giant museum and you're in
this cavernous beautiful room it's
mostly empty now we could call that a
void
or we can call it beauty yeah we can
call it acceptance we can call it space
open space in fact when you uh when you
go to wyoming or montana
it's not like man when are they going to
start building all the condos here like
what are you doing with all this space
no it's like wow
look at all this open space isn't that
stunning so the void isn't bad and we've
been told that the void is bad and
therefore because it's bad we need to
fill it with things and when the things
don't work i need to fill it with
experiences when the experiences don't
work i need to fill it with people when
when the people don't work i need to
fill it with creativity when the
creativity doesn't work i need to fill
it with contribution but maybe the first
thing i need to do is know that the void
is just wide open space
and it can be beautiful
on its own
let's move on to our callers if you have
a question comment for our podcast give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
hey podcast show looks like we got a
call from charles in ottawa just
wondering what advice you have for
someone who's over 50
specifically 54 who's thinking of being
a minimalist
i already live in a one-bedroom
apartment with my wife so just that
space alone
requires us to maybe have
fewer things than most people our age
but we still think we could do more
however unlike the 30 year old
minimalist the things we do have have
been with us for a lot more years so
what advice would you have
for people in that age bracket who are
trying to let go of things that maybe
they've had for 30 plus years
so josh how can we help charles get more
minimalism in his life
fill the void with minimalism no i think
it's a fascinating question because
really what he's saying here is i've
grown more attached to these things over
the years that is what we call
sentimentality incident mentality isn't
good or bad but it does mean excess
sentiment
right and so
sometimes i have excess sentiment for
someone for people especially for you
ryan i mean i i have much more
sentimentality toward you than i do a
random person i run across
uh on the street sure and yet
quite often this sentimentality this
excess sentiment
puts things in a skewed perspective
you and i've been to the dolly museum a
few times in st petersburg florida one
of my favorites it really is it's
stunning he's a surrealist and he
changes the perspective of things so
it's real but it's also surreal
and that's what happens with our
sentimental items they're real to us
but the sentiment is not real it is
surreal in a way it is it keeps us clean
to those things because oh i've had it
for so long and therefore it must mean
more to me well nothing is inherently
sentimental
and so we can assign whatever meaning we
want to our things
but if everything is meaningful to you
then nothing is truly meaningful i
remember when i was dealing with my
mom's stuff and packing up all of her
things and i realized that oh my god i'm
gonna have a hundred thousand
sentimental items
well i'm just watering down the things
that i might be able to get value from
in fact i'm cluttering the
sentimentality with more sentimentality
i'm cluttering the sentiment with more
sentimentality and so
it wasn't about getting rid of all of
her stuff though it was about two things
one it was about having fewer things so
i could enjoy the sentimental things
much more but second and more important
it was about
not holding on to the meaning that i
thought those things had understanding
it wasn't now it's not about letting go
through a process here are the three
ways to let go of sentimental items no
no it's about understanding that these
things
aren't serving me in any way they're
actually getting in the way so charles
lives in a one-bedroom apartment with
his wife
well it's possible to be a hoarder in a
one-bedroom apartment sure in fact in
many ways it's easier because you don't
have a bunch of places to put your stuff
right yeah danny just moved into a a
tiny apartment and he knows this right
now because he's like he's like oh i
have to be really careful with what i
what i bring in here because otherwise
it's going to clutter up the space
really quickly i think about our friend
joshua becker who's in our first
documentary minimalism we went out to
their house in
arizona right outside of phoenix
they live in the suburbs cul-de-sac
neighborhood a decent sized house right
not a mansion not too big but a lot of
open
space oh yeah
and
what i enjoy about that is that is also
hard because we often feel if you have a
four bedroom house because he and his
wife i think they have a three three
bedroom house he and his wife and both
of their kids
well if you have all that space
it feels really easy to fill in fact you
feel compelled i don't know got to fill
the void yeah
and
that often makes us miserable because
what's happening now whether you are 30
years old 40 years old or 54 years old
like charles you can become a minimalist
at any stage in your life we've had
people in their 90s come to our events i
remember a great grandmother who came to
our
san diego san diego event brought three
generations of daughters with her that
was pretty cool they were all going
through their own version of
simplifying and yes while it looked
different for each of them it's going to
look different for every person if you
take two 24 year olds who are embracing
minimalism
it always starts with the benefits it's
the reason we started our last
um netflix film less is now with that
question how might your life be better
with less
and so charles you've got to start with
that question as well if you're if
you're already a minimalist you're
already simplifying how might your life
be better with less and the truth might
be it's not going to be and
that means don't deprive yourself don't
feel that you need to be a spartan if
you go back to episode 300 ryan and i
did a whole episode about spartanism the
inability to hold on to anything that is
the opposite of hoarding in some ways
but it's still on the same continuum
both of those things have the ability to
get in the way man charles i just want
to say congrats man on
you know doing this starting this
journey at an older age because
i feel like it would be very easy to use
that as an excuse to not ever start uh
this journey so i mean yeah kudos to you
man amen so the whole thing about
minimalism right it's it's living
intentionally it's about um
using your resources deliberately
so
charles
you live in a one-bedroom apartment i
mean i would dare to say
like
maybe you need a two-bedroom apartment i
don't know yeah but minimalism isn't
about just like how can i how can i get
rid of more things how can i be more of
a minimalist
uh
really the minimalism is this you know
trojan horse for josh and i to talk
about the the way uh the way we live
meaningful lives and for you to
you know take some of those ingredients
so
seriously like look at europe
do you do
is the one bedroom apartment suiting you
if it is great right but don't deprive
yourself just for the sake of like what
would ryan and josh do or yeah whatever
um but but i'll tell you
if if there's anything i i would
recommend because i feel like i could
give this advice to anybody if you're in
a position
to where you can you have the the the
privilege or the luxury of sitting
around and saying okay what what more
can i do to live a meaningful life
find ways to give charles like there's
there's no better way than to um
to
not fill the void but to narrow it a
little bit when you give to someone else
like i i really enjoy whether it's you
know buying a homeless person a sandwich
or whether it's doing something for my
brother
there is this there is this uh
almost elation that you get from giving
when you do that the void no longer
matters yeah so so charles if anything
man um
make sure that a your
the way you're living your life is
conducive for you and your wife and if
it is great if you're looking for more
the question isn't what can i do to get
rid of more maybe the question is how
can i give more yeah yeah and and the
deprivation piece i think is really
important ryan because sometimes it does
make sense to temporarily deprive
yourself sure when you did your packing
party it was hey i'm going to get rid of
these things for three weeks figure out
what actually adds value but if you're
beyond that that point it's not
long-term deprivation that can be
harmful to you the other thing i'll say
is minimalism
is not the point of doing whatever
you're doing
it's not the end goal it's not the
destination
it is not where you're headed i'm going
to be a minimalist someday that is not
a virtuous goal
that's like saying i'm gonna own a
hammer someday right okay
great what are you gonna do with that
hammer right what are you going to do
with the new found time and attention
and resources that you have that's a
great example like are you going to
bludgeon someone with it right or are
you going to go work on habitat for
humanity with it yes yeah and either one
of those things or something you can do
with a hammer
or you can just sit in a drawer and do
nothing with it and then it's wasted
in general so so i think that when i
when i think about minimalism and
deprivation yes you'll temporarily
deprive yourself to figure out what adds
value to your life it starts with the
stuff but what else what else is sucking
your attention is it your smartphone is
it your tv is it your internet
connection
whatever it is you can remove that from
your life for a period of time maybe
it's processed foods
what what is excess in your life you can
start there temporarily remove it and
then slowly reintroduce the things that
actually add value yeah i love that
example of the hammer sitting in a
drawer because i think people will look
at you and i'm like oh well these guys
were miserable
and then they found minimalism and now
they're preaching from the mountaintops
so i need to be a minimalist but
yeah becoming a minimalist is just the
first step yeah um
a lot a lot of people ask i mean how
many times do we get the question where
they're like
man i've like
minimized i've downsized i've organized
uh i got really good relationships in my
life but now what
right now now like i don't know what to
do with my time and i would say like
that's probably the hardest part about
the whole journey is like figuring out
what do you do with your time and the
other problem we have is thinking we
need to fill the time now yeah it's true
too oh i guess i'm supposed to do this i
got rid of this what should i replace it
with i got rid of this relationship what
should i replace it with i got rid of
this item what should i replace it with
i got rid of this career what should i
replace it with i got rid of this home
what should i replace it with well maybe
you don't need to replace it with
anything maybe you can make peace and
even
feel peace because of that void because
of that open space that you've opened up
in your own life
you can tick-tock that danny unknown
alabama let's oh before we get into some
patreon comments from the live stream
here
charles i want to send you a couple
tickets you are in ontario we're going
to be in ontario really soon heck yeah
this is our 10th tour in 11 years it's
called the love people use things tour
ryan and i have already done nine of
those events and in january and february
we're going to be in 11 other cities
we'll be in new york and boston and dc
and toronto and columbus and chicago
and minneapolis and vancouver and
seattle san francisco and here in los
angeles ryan gives a talk about
minimalism we're gonna do a live version
of the podcast we're gonna answer your
questions also i'm gonna read from our
new book which is called love people use
things so charles i'd love to give you a
couple tickets to our toronto event if
you want to make that couple hour drive
from
ottawa anyone else can go to the
minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you let's check
in with the live stream real quick do
you have any comments from our patreon
supporters we do ricardo says love the
behind the scenes
he also adds impending retirement helps
one to become a minimalist yeah we also
have a comment from sam that says the
tech team is doing a great job
we got jordan no more here podcast sean
alabama and danny unknown all behind the
cameras they're helping out a ton also
shout out to jess social jess she's
she's here in spirit as well as emma the
immigrant ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
landing round where we answer your text
messages you can text your questions and
comments too 937-202-4654
yes indeed now during the lightning
round this is where ryan and i do our
best to answer questions with a short
share of a less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media and by the way you can find
all of our minimal maxims in one place
now
minimalmaxims.com lisa has a question
for us in an alternate universe where
you have the power to make everyone in
the world a minimalist according to your
rules and blogs do you use your power to
do it hell no that doesn't sound like
the all that doesn't what did they say
the um oh in an alternate i thought it
was uh in the ultimate universe i'm like
that that sounds miserable right
so let's talk about why it sounds
miserable so here's here's my pithy
answer then we'll unpack it to persuade
someone
is to unlove them
now let's talk about that because
i for most of my life
and in fact i want to talk about this on
the private podcast i've learned so much
over the last two years ryan it has
nothing to do with the pandemic
um although maybe the pandemic opened up
some space for for some deeper
understanding but
i'll tell you this
i used to want to persuade people
because i thought that was how i could
love them if i could just convince them
coerce them is really the way to say it
persuasion's a very nice friendly way to
say i'm going to coerce you oh yeah i'm
going to persuade you to see my point of
view now i can give you my point of view
my perspective
and if i don't have that desire to
persuade you quite often it may persuade
you but trying to persuade someone
is where we often go wrong because it
inadvertently places us on a pedestal
i'm thinking if ryan if we
if we had that magic wand we could wave
it now everyone is a minimalist
are you familiar with uh turkmenistan
the country they had this dictator their
um their main city which is called
ashgabat they um
it's stunning and it looks like this
weird
pseudo-minimalist paradise in a way all
the buildings are white marble there oh
wow so they have this huge natural gas
reserve so they have tons of money there
right
but when you central plan something and
and
and you do it this in fact all the cars
there are white as well because the
dictator didn't like red cars or blue
cars or whatever really and so
me someone like me going there i'd be
like oh this is astonishing right but
the problem is when you force that upon
everyone else
yeah it makes them miserable it's the
dale carnegie quote which i often
attributed to pt barnum for some reason
but uh dale carnegie said
a man convinced against his will is of
the same opinion still
and so if i could convince everyone to
become a minimalist they wouldn't
actually be a minimalist
they would be forced they'd be
constricted they'd be restricted that's
not minimalism because as ryan said
earlier minimalism is about using your
resources intentionally well if you
don't have any other choice then how
could you possibly be
intentional um
yeah that
that much power seems um
yeah it just it seems daunting it seems
like when someone has that much power
they're inevitably going to be corrupted
and the reason being is is you can't
please everyone with that type of power
so there's going to be some people who
you have to ignore their
preferences and i don't like ignoring
people's preferences right but you're
right in that situation you might have
to there's only two options there is you
either will eventually become corrupted
by that much power
or you'll have to let it go i think
about the president calvin coolidge who
was truly a president he presided over
the country he didn't even run for
another term because it was like i don't
want this power but of course someone's
always going to come in and try to grab
that power away usually the wrong people
too um
it's yeah anyone who like is
really vying to be president like you've
got a question like what are their
intentions yes like what are they what
are they really after
um
my pithy answer is this i'd rather
empower someone than exert power over
someone
so you know i joked around about the um
during the cultish episode how i want to
start a cult
[Music]
the only reason i would want to start a
cult is so i could like
help empower people it wouldn't be so i
could preside over them right and be
like here's the way we're going to do it
well you could preside but you wouldn't
be
trying to corral them in a way right
yeah yeah i see what you're saying by
preside there so yeah in that sense yes
i would be but it would be more about
like
having having a group of people who are
really uh are
are empowered themselves to live the
lives that they want to live right um
but it turns out you know we're already
kind of a cult so you know
dream come true welcome aboard
minimizers that's right that's right we
got so much more to talk about but first
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist as you can see we're in this
beautiful new studio we spent the other
day building this giant desk well when i
say we it was mostly jordan no more he's
rather handy
and the desk showed up it's custom made
shout out to our patreon supporters for
making this studio possible yeah it is
truly stunning and i hesitate to say
this you can see the art behind us from
beulah
beautiful beautiful art the studio is
still about 90 complete right now
another 10 percent to go
but our old paintings that were in here
we had her paint these two giant ones
which are going to be
hung
people are hanged paintings are hung uh
they're gonna be hung tomorrow
from uh from the ceiling and so you're
actually getting to see sort of behind
the scenes look right now but we had
four older paintings in here and i
hesitate to say this because we're
offering them to our patrons first so by
the time this comes out they might
already be gone but beulah is selling
those four paintings if you want them um
the minimalists.com
art that just takes you to her website
it's not our website but it's a quick
forward because i couldn't remember the
the url so if you want to own a piece of
the minimalist studio no pressure
they're not going to make you more
complete they're not going to make your
life better or improved they might add a
little beauty to your home but you'll be
just fine without them but if you are
interested all four of those paintings
are available at the minimalist.com art
and if you want to see a studio tour
we've got four of them up right now
of the minimalists podcast studio the
fifth and final one is coming real soon
those are all available over at patreon
mal what do you got for us here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners hi my name is yasin bera i'm
from winnipeg manitoba i'm calling to
leave a voicemail in response to the
episode on jobs uh there's a common
thread in your work that relates to
living a meaningful life and a lot of
the discussion around jobs tends to
relate to
finding meaningful work and i think a
shortcut uh to finding meaningful work
is actually to just introduce the
elements of helping people
to pretty much any kind of work so if
you were to take
any sort of job and just introduce an
element of helping people to the actual
content of the work that's a direct
route to finding more meaning in that
work um in my case
i've done just that by uh by quitting
the the corporate job in order to start
a a social enterprise and that's kind of
my my tip for this uh this message is
the concept of a social enterprise is
something that people maybe want to
familiarize themselves with which is to
say
basically conducting any sort of typical
business but perhaps structured as a
non-profit where proceeds are used to
advance some sort of social or
environmental cause
and in that way you're combining
potentially the skills that you've uh
you've acquired in the context of a
regular job and coupling them with the
idea of helping people
and i found that to be a really really
great way to find meaning in my work
hi minimalists this is elizabeth from
south jordan utah and i was just
listening to your podcast about friends
and relationships and particularly your
response to rebecca's question
about how to improve relationships or
move on after a relationship ends
as someone who does believe that
relationships are one of the things that
we take with us when we go so to speak i
really appreciate your advice on
how to
take inventory of relationships
to make sure that we're all staying on
the on the right track and on the path
that we want to be
i would add to your advice to rebecca
though just kind of a cautionary word
that
the idea of not settling can sometimes
turn into knit picking
and i would say that that's a very fine
line
but an important one to remember
that
if not settling
means that you have such a long laundry
list of traits
that you're never able to actually
commit to anyone you're going to have a
long and miserable dating life
i would also add
that it's important to remember that
sometimes the people who are the best
for us
are the ones who
challenge us the most and in many ways
are the most different from us i know
that's been my experience with my
relationship with my husband
and i wanted to put that out there for
anyone else who's listening that just
because it might be hard or challenging
doesn't mean that you're settling in
some ways uh you might be winning
in those situations
more than others
happy anniversary ryan happy anniversary
we did it 11 years what is it again
turquoise anniversary turquoise yes we
did it
here we are turquoise year
well you've added a lot of value to my
life ryan i appreciate you i appreciate
everyone here speaking of added value
we've moved our added value segment over
to the private podcast we got a great
added value for you this week speaking
of the private podcast here's a loving
testimonial from deborah she says i
stumbled into your podcast by accident
that's what happened with us in
minimalism right pretty much i just
stumbled into minimal and thankfully it
wasn't like a cult like a a detrimental
cult where i was like i had to join and
like shave my head and i'll tell you
what the white colin wright is so
handsome i would follow him into any
cult
colin is the one who introduced us to
minimalism initially anyway uh deborah
says she stumbled into the podcast by
accident it really struck a chord with
me
i like the thoughtful approach and
camaraderie you guys share ever since i
started listening i've been decluttering
and enjoying living with less and i
finally decided that it was time to
commit to being a simpleton that's what
we call our uh our private podcast
supporters by the way simpletons because
ryan and i are the heads of the head
simpletons yes she said mainly because i
hated the thought of you guys having fun
without me well you're all welcome to
join i should just thank you for
producing a wonderful helpful private
podcast guys by the way we have a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
in what ways is digital clutter better
than physical clutter what have the
minimalists learned so far about
minimizing life's internal clutter like
stress depression and worry and looking
back on the past 11 years is there
anything you did at the beginning of
your journey that you would change if
you could plus a million more questions
for the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast visit patreon.com the
minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tiktok instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalists if you want our podcast
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast john alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburt reminding you
to love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'd be fine without it